My Name is Vivian Hughbanks, and I'm homeschooled
from Signal Mountain Tennessee.
I graduated in 2012.
Now I'm a journalism German and politics major
at Hillsdale College and a member of the Dow
Journalism program.
This semester I'm interning at Town Hall Media
as part of Hillsdale's Washington Hillsdale
Internship Program.
The Washington Hillsdale Internship Program,
we call it WHIP for short, We bring anywhere
between ten to twenty students a semester
out to DC.
They take two or three classes and they intern
on the hill, at the Heritage Foundation, really
anywhere want to.
When we find somebody coming out of college
who has some practical real world experience,
especially experience that applies to what
we do, it really sets them apart.
Washington is one of those places that kids
can learn a lot and gain a lot just from being
hear for a few months.
And in that since coming here and having that
interning experience, I can guarantee will
be life changing.